parfait il n'y a pas un nuage
le temps idéal pour un arc en ciel si si
un arc en ciel que nous allons fabriquer
mais non pas avec des cris en couleurs
suivez-moi
[Musique]
et voilà je suis prêt
pour faire pousser un arc en ciel il
faut de l'eau sous forme de gouttelettes
et du soleil enfin la lumière émise par
le soleil
c'est parti
la lumière pénètre dans les gouttes
d'eau se réfléchit côté opposé avant de
ressortir à l'air libre
chaque goutte agit un peu comme un
miroir par conséquent pour observer un
arc en ciel l'observateur doit se
trouver entre le soleil et le rideau de
pluie le dos tourné au soleil et le
regard orienté vers la paix
si cet agencement change l'arc-en-ciel
disparaît la preuve dans la petite
caméra bouge l'arc en ciel n'est plus
visible
allez on en profite encore un peu c'est
beau alors d'où sortent toutes ses
couleurs
[Musique]
une goutte d'eau est pourtant
parfaitement écolo
en fait la lumière émise par le soleil
et blanche tous les spationautes
confirmeront le soleil qu'il voit se
lever 16 fois par jour à bord de la
station spatiale internationale
les blancs et non pas jaune comme sur
les tableaux des grands pas alors nous
aurait-il menti et voilà le spectre du
grand complot qui ressurgit eh bien non
vue du plancher des vaches
le soleil est bien jaune est notable
c'est parce que la lumière blanche est
constitué de plusieurs couleurs les
fameuses couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel
seulement avant d'arriver jusqu'à nous
certaines zones celles qui correspondent
à la couleur bleue sont déviés et
diffusée par l'atmosphère privé d'une
partie du bleu la lumière blanche tirs
sur le jaune mais revenons aux couleurs
de l'arc en ciel
quand elle pénètre dans une goutte d'eau
et la lumière change 2010 elle passe de
l'air à l'eau puis de gros a l'air à ce
moment là elle est déviée c'est un
phénomène que vous connaissez tous très
bien quand un bâton est plongé dans
l'eau vu de l'extérieur il semble brisée
parce que la lumière et des villes les
zones qui correspondent aux différentes
couleurs qui cantonne la lumière blanche
sont toutes des vielles différemment le
violet est davantage dévié que le verre
qu'il est davantage que le jaune etc
du coup les couleurs sont séparés et
elles sont toutes réfléchir dans des
directions légèrement différente
c'est ce qui donne naissance à l'arc en
ciel et permet d'observer le spectre de
la lumière visible maintenant un peu
d'histoire
c'est le savant anglais isaac newton qui
en 1660 à le premier expliquer le
phénomène
le même qui est un peu plus tarder à
formuler la loi de l'attraction
universelle en observant nous dit la
légende la chute d'une pomme
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai
accroché son portrait au milieu des
pommiers pour situer le personnage plus
facilement pour illustrer sa théorie sur
la composition de la lumière
isaac newton s'appuie sur une expérience
qu'il réalise en public et qui consiste
à faire passer de la lumière à travers
un prisme comme si
mais il a beau faire l'expérience dans
un sens ou dans un autre
décomposé ou recomposées la lumière en
libé a un peu de mal à passer dans la
population surtout lorsqu'il explique
qu'un arc en ciel n'est rien d'autre que
l'illustration de ce phénomène pour
convaincre ses contemporains il imagine
un petit disque qui depuis porte sombre
et sur lequel ils pas les couleurs de
l'arc en ciel en le faisant tourner
rapidement évidemment à l'époque il n'a
pas de moteur électrique
tout devient clair comme de l'eau de
roche enfin lancôme du les plages violé
le vert jaune orange rouge six couleurs
il en manque une pour compléter le
spectre de l'arc-en-ciel l'indigo alors
pourquoi avoir ajouté une septième
couleurs entre le violet bleu est pas
une huitième entre le bleu et le vert
une neuvième entre le vert et le jaune
etc etc
certains experts rappellent que newton
était également théologien or le chiffre
7 dans la religion chrétienne est un
symbole fort
les sept péchés capitaux les sept jours
de la semaine le septième ciel c'est
peut-être pour cette raison que newton a
tenu à ce que l'arc en ciel soit composé
de cette couleur c'est le seul côté
obscur de ce personnage des lumières
mais qui n'a pas fait d'ombré à sa
notoriété
allez à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
capsule 2d confiné longo et n'oubliez
pas nous sommes des confiné
nous restons lire
[Musique]
il